first off congratulations i absolutely
adore your movie
adele my first question is for you was
writing for the animated feature format
always a goal of yours or did this
opportunity kind of come out of the blue
it came out of the clear blue sky and i
am so excited that it did
you know i grew up in malaysia i grew up
watching disney movies and i don't think
it was in my wildest dreams that i
thought i'd be
you know helping to write um on one
but the idea that i was going to be part
of creating you know the next disney
warrior princess and have the culture be
inspired by where i grew up like that's
crazy um so anyway um the eight-year-old
in me would have just shrieked with
delight
and would be so proud of you now i still
can't get over this story
what would you say was the biggest
lesson learned or maybe the most
challenging pivot to make when it comes
from going from
writing for live action to writing for
animation
you know strangely because most of my
career it was as a tv writer
it actually was the perfect sort of
transition and fit i think for uh
feature writers
you know you have this idea of future
writers you know on their laptops by
themselves at a coffee shop
and that could not be further from the
truth when it comes to feature animation
it is incredibly collaborative
so instead of going into a room with a
big table surrounded by writers i'm
surrounded by
the most talented story artists in the
world so when even when it came to
breaking story you know and you're
we have all these pictures of like like
thousands of cards pinned up on the wall
you know coming up with like what the
big themes of the story are who the
individual characters are what their
arts are going to be
i had all these teammates in the story
department and even in the writing of it
um you know i'd write a scene and then
you know fawn versus thor would take it
and you know put in all these amazing
visual
ideas and dynamics and even lines
because these story artists um what i
hadn't realized they're cinematographers
and directors and writers
um so being able to be inspired by their
boards i would write to that and then
they would write to my script so it is
this sort of cyclical
like you know process of inspiration um
you know that is that is tremendous
that you don't have to do it alone as a
writer thank god
so oh it's not now i believe this is
your second feature
as a full producer on the production so
is there any
tool in your producing toolkit so to
speak that you would
credit with having worked on moana that
you're now applying to
raya yeah i think there are quite a few
actually one of the most important
things i think though was um
discovering a way that worked for us to
work with
um experts cultural experts from the
region with the oceanic story trust on
moana
i'm still in touch with almost everyone
on it because these great friendships
for
and so we we applied that on with our
southeast asia story trust as well we
had a
a visual cultural anthropologist which
is so interesting this sort of expertise
is the visual representation of anything
within culture he's lao
but he's his knowledge is throughout the
region and we had so many experts like
that that joined us along the way
i think um there are there are a million
tools though because
the truth is that um you really do have
to trust the process when it's a process
this long
it sometimes feels like you're going
backwards we try something we push
against some idea
and then we do a screening with our with
our story trust and oops
we went too far in one direction or
another you have to trust that we are
always
getting getting there making something
better and better and better and once
you've done it once you can trust it
that much more easily
was there any point in this process
where there was a new idea being
implemented and you're like i don't know
about this i don't know if it's going to
work and then all of a sudden later on
it clicked and you saw that that was the
right move for the story and the
characters
that happens so often in all parts of
the story process because we really we
put it up we break it all down
and sometimes you get attached to an old
idea and you know when a brave new idea
is put forth i think a great example is
you know to give credit to don hall um
this idea of the the ending and what
that act of trust
um you know is going to look like in the
climax of the movie
and we you know there are many stories
about you know pulling people together
for a common goal
but if the if the if the underlying
message is about trust how do we show
that in the last
movie it's not about being the biggest
strongest warrior in the room you know
ryan
namara could easily be that but it is
this uh ultimate act of sacrifice and
showing that you
are this person who is worthy of being
trusted
um you know and rai who has no reason to
trust anyone
after being betrayed so you know so much
she still finds the strength to reach
out because she is the hero of that
movie
um i think it was the idea of that and
then you know um having the
incredibly talented uh john rip our
co-director you know put
up those boards and we all saw and
immediately were struck by the
emotionality of that moment
uh you know i think that that was the
the prime example of like having a very
hard to work around concept
intellectually
and then seeing it realize and seeing
that it worked better than anything you
could have thought of
i think for me it's um it's less
something that i didn't think would work
it's more something that i didn't think
we'd get away with
which was um having three strong
interesting
nuanced female leads and
exploring at the very heart of a a major
feature a friendship between two female
characters and
and even that opposition kind of
friendship relationship that ray has
with namari
so i um nobody ever said no and so it's
something that we pushed on and and
um adele and in particular could not be
more excited about
just a last act to add on to that which
was i think we you know because austin
and i got so excited about you know
creating these characters at one point
we actually looked up and realized like
oh all our characters are female
including tong
you know started as a female character
and i never thought we'd ever be in this
position of thinking well maybe
you know for equity we need to like uh
you know have
one more male character what was it like
formulating that group of heroes that we
see
together throughout the movie was was
there any kind of mixing and matching
along the way adding and subtracting
anything like that
yeah there was a young baby noise she
started off as
uh actually tong was a grandmother um
has the grandchild and they were
together she was a warrior a warrior
baby she already had that
tough thing that we love so much about
her and we realized as we looked at it
that
at that point we had the ongi's where
they were the main the monkey kind of
characters
the main characters from from uh talon
and we wanted a human
character there and came up with the
idea of how she works with them
um boone was somewhere else to begin
with and
we've moved him they evolved and we
thought of him as you know the
the han solo he's the he's the getaway
the getaway car
is our is our emporium and you know all
those parallels the way we talk
and shorthand with each other but it was
super fun to come up with them and they
we did and when they landed when
we and especially when a voice actor
would come in like
benedict ron came in and and and and
brought tong to life and you knew okay
we're really on to we're on to something
pitch perfect casting
i did have one off topic question for
you because
what you did on the crazy rich asian
sequel is
i imagine a very scary thing to do but
it's also a very important stand to make
so for any
other writer out there who might run
into a similar situation given the fact
that you've already gone through it
what would you advise them to do you
know i think you can only speak to your
truth
um you know with what crazy rich and
similar to ryan it has done so much for
asian representation
and you know you want to be able to have
people uh behind the scenes as well
you know telling those stories there's
um you know it all comes down to
um saying we have for underrepresented
communities that know stories about us
without us
and so you know i think disney's great
credit um it's not just me
and my co-writer qui gwen but we had so
many um people um from southeast asia or
had southeast asian cultural roots
already in the disney family with our
you know our story department visual
development um you know uh
uh in animation we're able to give that
layer of authenticity and you know
dedication and love to the project
and so really that's what you know
that's what you love to see and
hopefully you know
all the whole industry is you know
striving towards a
more diverse and uh accurate reflection
of the world we live in today
with faces in front of and behind the
screen i appreciate you sharing that
thank you both so much for your time
today my one and a half year old niece
is obsessed with moana and i am
determined to make raya next on that
list
i love it